important
all right so uh welcome to uh the uh
last talk of today uh we're uh I'm
delighted to introduce my uh uh former
student uh have you graduated yet
William kretchmer uh this summer in any
case someplace
uh
uh graduating and actually
here at Simon's and he's going to talk
about uh joint work actually with uh
three uh of our other students in our
group at UT Austin on a learning Beyond
stabilizers
uh all right well thanks for the
introduction uh my understanding is that
we originally had a different speaker
scheduled for today and they were not
able to make it and I was asked to fill
in and I agreed on the condition that I
didn't actually have to talk about
quantum gravity on the quantum gravity
day so uh instead you'll hear me talking
about as Scott said learning Beyond
stabilizer States
um which is based on joint work with uh
three wonderful co-authors Alby Grewal
bishnu Ayer and Daniel Liang who all
contributed equally to these papers
the material I'll be talking about is
currently split across I guess three
different uh papers on archive and
possibly more to come
um
so with that I'll get started and uh so
what this talk is about a fundamental
topic of study in Quantum information is
understanding uh how much we can learn
from a Quantum State uh or put another
way just one of the central questions we
try to understand is how hard is it to
learn a Quantum state
and I do not have enough time in this
talk to survey the entire field of
quantum learning theory uh much less do
so in a single slide but I at least want
to give you a few of the highlights
starting with the fact that in some
sense we know the answer to this
question is really hard in particular if
you have an unknown n qubit Quantum
State even if it's a pure State and you
want to do full tomography on the state
which just means that you want to learn
a complete description of the state that
lets you accurately predict any possible
uh future measurement of that state then
you need an exponential number of
samples in the system size
and kind of the the main place that this
has you know diverted attention to in
Quantum planning theory is trying to
understand when this exponential scaling
can be avoided
and there are in my view basically two
approaches to this problem that have uh
gotten a lot of focus in the the recent
years
the first approach is to just relax what
it means to learn this state so rather
than trying to learn a complete
description of the state as you do in
full tomography you for example maybe
just try to predict the state's behavior
on some restricted set of measurements
like you might do in the shadow
tomography or pack learning models for
Quantum States
and there have been a lot of success
stories in recent years on vastly
reducing the sample complexity needed
for these kinds of learnings compared to
photography but unfortunately except in
some very restricted settings even these
learning tasks still often remain very
computationally inefficient even if the
sample complexity the number of copies
of the state that you need is low
and pretty much the only hope that
leaves for getting truly efficient
Quantum learning algorithms is to look
at more restricted classes of states
uh and there there's actually been quite
a few developments in really just the
last few years showing that a a wide
range of Highly non-trivial and
expressive classes of quantum States
actually admit efficient learning
algorithms including things like low
Dewey Quantum phase States matrix
product States free fermion states or
what will be the the focus of this of
this talk the set of stabilizer States
and uh to Briefly summarize what the
stock is going to be about and what we
achieve in these works we give a variety
of new learning algorithms for classes
of quantum states that generalize the
set of stabilizer States
and the common thread in these
algorithms is that in each of these
algorithms the the runtime the
complexity of the learning scales with
some measure of the amount of
non-stabiliziness in the state
and of course in you know the next few
slides I'll explain to you what I really
mean by non-stabiliziness but this is
kind of the high level intuition
and
um to really dive into you know what
this talk is going to be about I do want
to at least review hopefully for many of
you the basics of the stabilizer
formalism
and probably the best place to start is
by defining the Clifford Group which is
the uh well it's perhaps the single most
important subgroup of the unitary group
and Quantum information it is the group
of unitary Transformations that is
generated by these three gates the
hadamard gate the phase gate and the C
naught gate and uh the skate set has a
lot of nice properties
um first off you'll notice that this uh
the set of gates is capable of
generating Quantum superpositions uh
complex phases and in particular
interference and also entanglement
between Quantum subsystems which are
three of the essential features of
quantum computation that can give it
advantages over classical algorithms
uh but of course nevertheless we know
that the skate set is actually not
Universal for Quantum computations uh
and in fact something even stronger is
true uh it turns out that you can
actually efficiently simulate on a on a
classical computer the evolution of any
Quantum circuit composed entirely of
Clifford Gates
um but despite this you know as I
mentioned before this this Clifford
group finds numerous applications in
Quantum information which can largely be
attributed to the very nice algebraic
structure of the skate set and we see
that you know that the set of Clifford
Gates
for example it shows up in in
constructing error correcting Quantum
codes and fault tolerance in building
efficient tea designs and also in some
of the learning algorithms we saw for
shadow tomography
foreign
structure that that makes the Clifford
group so nice uh well one way of
explaining it is that uh the the set of
outputs that you can get by applying a
Clifford circuit to the alzero state is
precisely the set of stabilizer States
and again you know presumably many of
you have heard about stabilized States
before but for those of you who haven't
we start by defining the poly matrices
which are just these single qubit
matrices i x y and z and we Define the N
qubit polygroup uh as the set of all
tensor products of these matrices on N
qubits along with arbitrary plus or
minus one or plus or minus I phases
and then a stabilizer state is just a
state with the property that it is
stabilized by exactly two to the N
different poly matrices where we say
that state is safe is stabilized by some
operator P that just means that PSI is a
plus one eigenstate of P
um and actually it will be convenient to
introduce this notation because we're
going to use it a lot throughout this
talk you can actually Define not just
for a stabilizer state but for an
arbitrary State its stabilizer group as
the the group of poly operators because
it's closed down to multiplication that
stabilize that state and I will denote
this by stab of catsai
uh good so as I mentioned at the start
of this talk uh one of the nice
properties of stabilizer States is that
they are efficiently learnable so there
is actually a polynomial time algorithm
that given copies of a stabilizer State
can uniquely recover the state with high
probability and this is due to the work
of uh I guess first observed by Ironton
and Bosman and later uh in in slightly
different uh in a slightly different
algorithm by montanaro and uh the idea
of these two algorithms is actually very
similar they both
at a very high level they involve
basically sampling uniformly random
elements of the stabilizer group and
then repeating this until you get a full
set of generators for this group which
is enough to determine the state
um and one question that has gotten some
attention in the last few years is
whether there's any sense in which we
can generalize this algorithm to more
General classes of states and in
particular uh you know this question has
kind of been explored partially in works
by by lion Chang and also our naturalum
Bravia and Yoder both in 22. where you
know they note that in Quantum
information there is a wide class of uh
there's actually many different classes
of quantum States uh that generalize the
set of stabilizer States
um and it's sort of natural to ask
whether any of these generalizations
also admit efficient learning algorithms
you can sample from the stabilizers of
the state don't you know this state
already
um so so like it's saying uh from copies
of the state there is a measurement you
can perform that will sample a uniformly
and that's how you use it to learn the
state yeah
any more questions
so these use coherent measurements or
single purpose good uh so the original
algorithm of erinson is and modest plant
only uses uh one copy of the state at a
time uh montenario's algorithm uses two
copies of the state at a time
I mean I think we noted that you can get
by with fewer copies if you may coherent
measurement right that's true so the
sample complexity of functionars
algorithm is better
um yeah
um good so in this work uh we're at
least going to look at a couple of these
measures of states that kind of
generalize the set of stabilizer States
in particular Clifford plus T States and
states that have bounded stabilizer
Fidelity and I'm going to tell you what
these mean uh starting with uh Clifford
plus T States
so I mentioned at the start of this talk
that uh if you take the set of of
Clifford Gates this is not a universal
gate set but it is actually well known
that it is almost Universal in the sense
that if you append any single qubit gate
to this gate set that is not a Clifford
gate the result is a gate set that is in
fact Universal for Quantum computation
a common choice of the gate that is
added to this gate set is the T gate
which is this diagonal gate that just
adds a phase of e to the I pi over 4 to
the cat one state which is chosen both
you know sometimes just for
I guess notational Elegance but also in
many cases mathematical convenience
and uh one thing that kind of has
cropped up again and again in Quantum
information in regards to these kinds of
preferred plus T gate sets is that there
are a variety of different you know
Quantum algorithms and protocols in
which there is a sense in which the
stabilizer excuse me the Clifford gates
are cheap and it is the non-clifford
gates that are kind of the The Limited
resource that you really want to
minimize
uh and this happens for instance in in
Quantum error correction where for a a
wide class of codes known as stabilizer
codes
um the the set of stabilizer gates are
much easier to implement on logical uh
encoded qubits because you can Implement
them transversally
and for similar reasons in Magic State
distillation where you know basically
you often kind of assume that you can
apply
um
these Clifford Gates basically for free
and then you just want to minimize the
number of non-clifford dates in your
circuit
uh and finally like another uh you know
interesting
um
you know something else that kind of
demonstrates this idea is is these uh
classical neoclifford simulation
algorithms which uh what they do is they
they can simulate a a circuit that is
dominated by Clifford Gates and they
usually have a runtime that scales
polynomially in the number of Clifford
Gates and then exponentially in the
number of non-clifford gates so as long
as the number of non-clifford gates is
small you still get an efficient
classical simulation
kind of the natural question that this
faces for Quantum State learning is
whether something similar happens for
learning Quantum States so if you have
the output of a circuit that is composed
you know mostly of Clifford Gates but
then just has a handful of t-gates you
know a natural question is can you learn
that state in polynomial time
um and the first result that I will talk
about is exactly a positive answer to
that question
so we show that if you have a Quantum
state that is the output of a Clifford
plus T circuit that has n qubits and at
most uh K T Gates then you can actually
learn that state and time that scales
polynomally in n and exponentially in
the number of TKS
and I should mention that actually at
basically the same time there were two
simultaneous works that achieved similar
results one by Leone oliviero and Tama
and one by hung glider and gullins which
we actually heard a little bit about
earlier this week in Dominic's talk
and it's the number of copies also
polynomial and N2 to the K yes yeah that
the number of copies yeah so time and
samples I should really say
um another thing I should note is that
I'm only going to be talking about like
Clifford plus T gates for Simplicity
um but actually pretty much all of our
results uh still holds if you actually
in fact all of our results still hold if
you replace the T gate by arbitrary a
simple qubit non-clifford Gates uh
basically all that changes is some
factors of two get added and sometimes
that two is just a multiplicative
constant sometimes it's a two and an
exponent but otherwise you know anytime
you see T Gates you can really think
arbitrary non-clifford Gates
foreign
good so this implies that you know in
particular if K is like uh you know
logarithmic in the number of qubits then
you can actually learn the state in
polynomial time
but this is actually not the end of the
story so uh there's a sense in which
this task does not immediately become
hard
um when K exceeds log n
because what we can also show is that if
you have the output of a Clifford plus T
circuit that has uh strictly less than n
t Gates then while you can't learn an
entire description of the state you can
at least do some weaker form of learning
in particular you can distinguish the
rate the state from from a random state
in polynomial time
or another way of saying this is that if
you have a state that is output by
Clifford plus T circuit with strictly
less than NT Gates then that state
cannot form a cryptographically uh or
that state
states of that form cannot form
cryptographic cryptographically secure
pseudo random ensembles
um good any questions about these
results
it's totally possible that there's a
there's an algorithm that goes like poly
and comma K like that would be
um
so I will kind of talk about it on the
next slide but like in short
um
that would sort of imply that you had a
polynomial time algorithm to just learn
arbitrary Quantum States out by output
by circuits of size k
and we wouldn't expect that to be true
like if if like cryptography like under
plausible photography that should be
hard
question yeah so when you say it can be
distinguished from random do you mean
like outputs of random circuits of
certain depths or I just mean like are
random States so it's like you have a
state which is promised to either be of
this form or it is promised to be a
uniformly random State then you can
distinguish those two cases with high
probability
yes maybe you said this but what do you
mean by learn like what's the good uh so
in this first case here learning just
means uh uh doing complete tomography on
the state so so you learn a classical
description of the state that is Epsilon
close in total uh in Trace distance what
is the description because you need it
is so say good
um
I guess we will see that later in the
talk but it does let you prepare the
state efficiently
um it is actually not a proper laminar
so uh if the circuit that prepares the
state is a Clifford plus T circuit the
description you learn is not necessarily
also a Clifford plus T circuit with the
same number of T Gates but wouldn't that
say to Robin's question that you can't
do it in polymk
uh
I haven't seen the relationship
like you need to be able to write down a
description
okay but like if you have a state okay
if that has a polynomial size circuit
yeah
yeah I think in Robin's question that
the barrier is just computational
yeah I mean I should know like um
I think it follows from like Shadow
tomography that like information
theoretically these kinds of texts are
easy
um if you just care about sample
complexity there are efficient
algorithms what's really the interesting
part here is the computational
complexity
so what is the model like when you say
that uh
good uh
uh you just get copies of the output
state
as many copies as you want
um
so these are actually the two results
I'm going to focus on for the rest of
the talk
um there are a few other results that I
don't think I really will have time to
go into detail about but I at least
wanted to mention them because I think
they're also interesting and they mostly
con concern a different measure of the
non-stabilizerness
so in this case we look at if you have a
state then like how many non-clifford
gates do you need to prepare that state
but a different measure of
non-stabiliziness that we looked at is
the so-called stabilizer fidelity and
intuitively that just measures like how
close your state is to a stabilized
estate
and we have some similar results where
we can show that if you have a state
with large stabilizer Fidelity you can
distinguish it from random
um you can sort of non-trivially
estimate the stabilizer Fidelity and
also
in some cases if the Fidelity is large
enough actually find the nearest
stabilizer state and then finally for
some of our results it actually turns
out that you can achieve the same things
using only single copy measurements so
you only get access to one copy of the
state at a time you can't perform
entangled measurements across different
copies
um
uh I think it was because we were really
trying to actually look at a different
Azure known as stabilizer extent
that in fact we're really trying to look
at something on a stabilizer rank
um because that was something that had
been raised explicitly as a question
and this was like as close as we could
get to that
but yeah I mean I mean I guess arguably
the stabilization Fidelity is like not
quite as well motivated as the Clifford
plus T circuits
again stabilizer Fidelity just means
largest Fidelity to any stabilizer
exactly
it sounds natural enough okay yeah I
thought so too
any other questions
uh that's my next slide so
um yeah so we sort of have two kinds of
results in this paper one is like the
week learning that I talked about which
is just distinguishing from random and
the other is like you know full
efficient learning and we study you know
both of these tasks with regard to you
know two measures and non-stabilizerness
one is the t-gount and one is the
stabilizer fidelity and at least in
three of these boxes so we have new
non-trivial algorithms and all four of
these boxes and in in three of these
boxes we can at least show that under
plausible cryptographic assumptions
um our results are basically tied up to
polynomial factors
good
um
so it's basically that you there are
like linear time constructable uh pseudo
random functions a Quantum secure random
functions
um I guess it's like admittedly not the
most well studied assumption but it's
like definitely a barrier like it's
basically saying like if you could
improve any of these results like you
know the reason wouldn't be because
you're you're really doing better on you
know learning uh near stabilizer States
it's just you're learning like arbitrary
outputs of quantum circuits better than
Brute Force
any other questions about this
okay good um that about sums up
everything I wanted to say about the
results
um and the rest of this talk like I said
I'll mostly focusing on the proof of the
results uh in this second column
concerning uh the t count they're
basically efficient learnability you
only get when you have a large overlap
with some examples
[Music]
um
sorry you're talking about this box for
a stabilizer fidelity
uh that's the only case in which we can
show its efficient
um it's it's plausible that if you have
like one over poly fidelicans that it
would work even that yeah and and and
and so so the algorithm is agnostic oh
we're meeting yeah okay so so it's like
technically not full learning of the
quantum State it's what we call agnostic
learning which just means uh basically
output any stabilizer state that has you
know at least that fidelity
I see absolutely which may not be the
the true one but uh but they're well
actually okay so sorry so this is
exactly the threshold yeah right which
there is a unique I was about to say
that yeah yeah it looks that looked like
it yeah so maybe calling this agnostics
yeah
you know it might start out agnostic but
then it proves that its stabilizer God
exists yeah
but
unless it just means that your stay is
not promised to be as stable as a
student right right like you're
basically saying like find me the
closest example from this concept class
where the concept class is the class of
Statewide
and it's saying like as long as you're
sufficiently close you can do that
efficiently
um I think maybe my single favorite open
problem from this work is whether you
can like push this below
that threshold and in particular to just
if you have like inverse polynomial
Fidelity yeah so good
any more questions
um so these little grounds so they come
from actually like learning classical
circuits or like the uh
um
I mean so again they're just like
they're pretty much all from
pseudorandom functions so it's just like
if you have
uh
well which I guess are in a sense just
classical circuits yeah so it's like
saying if you have an ensemble of
pseudonym functions that you can compute
like linear size classical circuits
um
but that cannot be distinguished from
random by exponential time Quantum
algorithms then these are basically
tight I guess actually maybe we really
only need that you have um
like linear time pseudo random States
um
yeah
so when you see that uh these results
are cryptographic type do you mean that
for instance if you have more than log n
please then there is no football uh
exactly like like you know if
um you know if you could learn states
that have you know more than log n t
Gates and polynomial time then like that
would that would imply you know a new
break through in cryptography basically
okay
any more questions about the results
okay good
uh so before I actually dive into
telling you about the proof techniques
I'm to take a step back and give you a
bit of a Zen Outlook about kind of
imagine this paper and presumably most
of you either know exactly what this
slide is about or have no idea what this
line is about
um and what this is about is an analogy
for solving uh math problems that was
suggested by Alexander grothendeek who
is depicted down here and he he
suggested that if you if you think of
the the mathematical problem you're
trying to solve as like a nut that you
are trying to open then there are two
different approaches by which you can
you can try to open that nut
the first is just a very direct approach
you know you you hit it with a blunt
object like a hammer until it starts to
crack and eventually by making enough
from blows you know the nut will finally
be opened and this kind of you know
Brute Force attack is what he described
as being the approach of mathematicians
like jean-piercera who's depicted up
here
but growth and Deek himself advocated
for a more indirect approach which is
you know rather than trying to directly
open the nut using boot Force you just
let the nuts soak in some softening
liquid like water and you let them soak
and soak and soak for as long as it
takes for the skin to soften
and eventually through you know
basically no effort of your own other
than maybe you know occasionally rubbing
the surface of the nut the nut will open
itself to you
um and this is the approach to
mathematics that that growth and deak
advocated for
um so you know why am I drawing upon
this analogy well I very much take the
view that uh this is kind of the
approach that our algorithms take
because what you will basically see is
that we develop a bunch of you know
Theory surrounding the algebraic
structure of these Clifford plus T
States but then once we've kind of
developed enough algebraic structure the
algorithms just fall out
um
and I actually also think this analogy
is appropriate because if I look back on
like how we came upon these results uh I
think it's fair to say that it was you
know kind of accidental we were really
just trying to understand you know the
structure of these Clifford plus T
States and then we realize that you can
get these algorithms from it
so
uh that's you know the high level
overview of what is to come uh so okay
oh yeah
I'm not sure if somebody asked this
before but
um if you if you wanted to distinguish
not between
um
yeah
something like what do you like you know
assuming
that the most efficient implementation
is by some Circuit of size
giving you a random circuit a random
State conditioned on
random so that's different the random
safe conditions on that it requires uh
more than I don't know N squared uh TKS
to less than three between N squared I
don't know
uh I think if it's like random circuits
then we should be able to
um I might have to to verify that
um but I mean you actually might answer
that question uh already in the next
couple
um
yeah because you as we'll see we'll
actually kind of go through actually a
different measure of like how close your
your state is to a stabilizer state
which I think you know it holds for all
states that have C count strictly less
than n but then I think if you have a
random state that has t counts larger
than them they would not have that
yeah
okay so so
I could say one thing you're also saying
is that
um
actually any n is the number uh number
of keywords
yeah
there's also one other caveat here which
is that here the perfect the
cryptographic tightness is only up to
constants so it's like you know we can
show that if you have less than NT Gates
uh it's easy and if you have more than
like
I don't know c times n t gets r
um technically in the intermediate
regime we don't know any
okay
um
good so
we're kind of just going to start with a
series of observations about these
Clifford plus T states which will lead
us directly to what we need to
understand about them
and the first thing we will observe is
that suppose we have some arbitrary
States PSI
it has some stabilizer group and we come
along and we apply a gate U to this
state PSI
so what happens well imagine uh just for
a moment that an element of this
stabilizer group that we'll call P
actually commutes with the gate U that
we apply
then I claim that this same poly
operator p is also in the stabilizer
group of the state after we apply to you
and the reason for this is very simple
just that if you look at P times U PSI
you can commute P past U to get U times
P of PSI
and then since P stabilize the side
that's just the same as use I and all of
this is just saying that P still
stabilizes U side
so again we're saying if
um
if the gate you applied commutes with an
element of the stabilizer group
then that element is still in in the
post gate stabilizer group
and you know to take an example if we
take the T gate which is a diagonal gate
the T gate commutes with poly I and poly
Z matrices and as a result you can show
by well basically a simple inductive
proof that if you have a state PSI
that is the output of some Clifford plus
T circuit with at most K many T Gates
then the size of the stabilizer group of
the state is at least 2 to the N minus k
for the intuitive reason that the T gate
it commutes with half of the poly
operators so each time you apply a t
gate to your at most cutting the size of
the stabilizer group in half
does this make sense
um so in some sense understanding the
structure of these Clifford plus T
circuits reduces to understanding the
structure of these states that have uh I
guess large stabilizer groups
so what can we say about these states
um it turns out we can say a lot in fact
these states have a very nice structure
um as captured by the following Lemma so
imagine we have a state that has a
stabilizer group of size 2 to the N
minus K so for example if it's the
output of a Clifford plus T circuit with
like K many T Gates
then you can always find a Clifford
circuit that sort of uh compresses out
all of the non-clifferidness of the
state into k qubits so in particular
there exists a Clifford circuit C that
you can apply to psi such that the
result is just the zero State on N minus
K qubits tensor some arbitrary State on
K qubits
so these states that have large
stabilizer groups have this you know
very clean structure and not only that
you can also compute this Clifford
circuit C efficiently given the
stabilizer group of PSI
um I should note that like I'm pretty
sure we are not the first people to
observe something like this in fact I
believe this is basically a restatement
of the fact that stabilizer codes can be
encoded and decoded using Clifford
circuits
um
but we also do care about the
computational efficiency here of finding
this Clifford circuit
you say efficiently is that on the size
of the stabilizer set or
um
uh it means like given a set of
generators for that stabilizer group uh
because they always exist one of size
um you can compute this Clifford circuit
in time polynomial impact okay so it's
on over the generator the number exactly
like it's like giving us a succinct
description to the statement otherwise
it would be like exponential basically
all the t-ness all the
non-stabilizerness gets compressed into
big exactly
can you also say something about cat
file like is it just t-states
uh good so that's
um
I don't know how to say something about
that and that's kind of exactly the
reason why we don't have like a proper
learning algorithm
um but I do get the sense that if you
could say something about that state
then you probably you know might get
you know more proper learning algorithms
for these classes at States
what's the best case scenario that's
like literally the t-state questions uh
like I guess it's something pretty nice
yeah he acting on cat zero does nothing
that's right here plus the state from
which you can do yeah
okay so uh yeah these you know these
states that have a large stabilizer
Group which again are you know a a
superset but the states that are outputs
of plus T circuits have this nice
structure and basically the conclusion
of this is that all of our results just
reduce to learning the stabilizer group
of an unknown Quantum state
um because if you want to learn the
state
um then you know I claim that you know
once you have learned the stabilizer
group you can compute this decomposition
and then just run tomography on this
Quantum State Phi which will take like
two to the K two to the K time which is
what we want
uh and and similarly for like our our
pseudo analyst result
um I guess there it's even simpler
because you know as soon as you identify
that PSI is stabilized by any list of
poly matrices that is sufficient to
distinguish it from a hard random State
because a hard random state is with
overwhelming probability far from any
state with that property
by the stabilizer group you mean the
totally stabilizer exactly yeah
yeah that's how we Define Stables yeah
so with this stage hi I don't think you
can really say much about it because an
extreme case would be when this original
state side is just
that's true yeah so if
um if PSI is an arbitrary state with
this property then Phi can also be
arbitrary that's true
um but I guess the main question is that
if PSI is just a state that is the
output of a Clifford plus T circuit does
that apply any more structure on Phi and
that I do not know the answer to
um but yeah but I guess like this will
also kind of be the sense in which like
our algorithms
may or may not be able to be improved
yes there's another question on the
previous slide you showed that it was
the number of TKS the stabilizer has
this number of poly stabilizers have a
lower ballot
um slightly confused can't you fight
isn't isn't it possible for the TKS to
be placed on specific qubits
shows more of the stabilizer
good
um
so when you apply a t gate to a single
qubit you know it can only kill the
stabilizers that are like non-identity
or Z on that qubit
um but I basically claim that like
because the the set of stabilizers of
some state is a group that that set like
has to be you know
at least half of the size at least have
it all stabilizer
yeah so again so so uh in in any uh
stabilizer group at least half of the
stabilizers uh restricted to any one
qubit have to be either the Identity or
Z
and by the way this is also where the
extra factor of two comes in if you
allow non-t Gates because what happens
is uh then you know arbitrary gate will
just commute with I
and so there instead of being reduced by
a factor of two it will be reduced by a
factor of four
okay any other question
good so
um
like I said really uh in some sense now
our entire goal is just given an unknown
State PSI how do you learn it to
stabilize a group efficiently
and the way we're going to do that is by
analyzing this function here
which I claim has a lot of nice
properties so what is this function so
for a poly operator W that's just a
tensor project of i x y and Z's you'll
Define this function PSI of w for any
pure State PSI as just the squared
expectation of this poly operator W uh
times this normalization factor of 1
over 2 to the f
okay so I've defined this uh what's so
nice about this function
uh the first thing is that I claim that
this function is actually a distribution
in other words if you if you look at the
the values over the set of poly
operators then they are all non-negative
and they sum to one
um the fact that they're non-negative is
easy to see because there's a square
the fact that they sum into one is a
little bit less trivial but it's like a
straightforward computation that's
related to the fact that PSI is assumed
to be a normalized state
um but I claim not only is this a
distribution but it actually has uh some
further structure to it in fact we can
almost sample from this distribution
efficiently uh given copies of PSI
um in particular we can't quite sample
from PSI itself but we can sample from a
closely related distribution that we
denote by QSI and this distribution QSI
is the convolution of PSI with itself
and the operational interpretation of
that convolution that just means that
you can think of QSI as taking two
samples from PSI and then multiplying
the results together
and actually the way you do this is by a
procedure known as Bell different
sampling
the details of which are not really
going to be that important for this talk
but you know I guess if people want me
to I could you know Define how this
works or you could just look at
Dominic's talk from early earlier this
week where he talked all about Bell
sampling
um I think there was something else I
wanted oh yeah uh one other note uh that
I want to make at this point is that
from now on do the rest of the talk
anytime I work with poly operators I'm
really going to actually be working with
those poly operators
modulo assign
um
and this kind of actually only makes
things easier
but if I really wanted to be proper
about this I would have to introduce
some different notation which I really
don't want to do so instead I'm just
going to kind of you know use poly
operators but with the understanding
that you know I don't care about the
phase information on those poly
operators
um okay so we have this function uh this
function PSI it's a distribution and we
can you know sample for something that's
pretty closely related to it
yes
why doesn't Bell sampling sample from
PSI great so what happens is that like
Bell sampling uh in the Fourier basis
uh will sample from like PSI plus a
shift
and
you sort of need to take a convolution
in order to cancel out that shift
I mean I guess that doesn't really
explain why like the realize you have to
do a calculation like see that there's
just this extra term but somehow that
term cancels once you take the
convolution
good so uh there's actually one other
property of PSI that we use that is
arguably really the key Lemma
um that makes all of our algorithms work
and it is the following uh that is this
actually really nice Duality property uh
of this function piece I on subgroups of
the polygroup
and it says the following
suppose you have a subgroup g of the
polygroup which again I'm going to be
thinking of as like a group modulo sign
so I'm just you know
complete completely ignoring the face
information of this group
if you look at uh the total mass that
this probability distribution places on
this subgroup G
then it is exactly proportional to the
mass that this function PSI places on a
closely related subgroup actually a dual
subgroup that I will denote by g-perp
um up to some constant of
proportionality that depends on the size
of G
um and
yeah so in other words it's saying that
like for any for any subgroup there's
like some dual subgroup where the mass
that PSI places on G is exactly
proportional to the mass it places on
that dual subgroup so so in particular G
and G perfect suppose have ordered two
to the N right then then it's an
interactive quality yes
yeah
um so what is this uh subgroup G curve
uh it turns out the subgroup G perf is
exactly uh the commutant of G so in
other words it is the set of poly
operators P such that uh p commutes with
every element of G
um and this actually really is a dual
subgroup so you can basically verify uh
that if you take the Dual uh if you take
the commutant of the commutant of a
polysub group you just get back your
original sub poop G
um good so somehow the the mass that PSI
places on Group G is related to the mass
that it places on the commutant of G
um so why is this useful
uh
so let's think about what happens when
we plug in uh G to be the stabilizer
group of PSI
so again this is just the set of poly
operators of which PSI is a plus one
eigenstate and because of how PSI is
defined if we sum over all W's and G of
you know one over two to n times PSI W
PSI squared
um since PSI W PSI is one because w
stabilizes i this is just the size of G
over 2 to the n
and so if we plug that into this
equation
the left hand side is G over 2 to the N
so the conclusion of this is that uh
the the this function PSI the sum over
the Dual subgroup is exactly one
or another way of saying this is that if
G is the stabilizer group of PSI
then all of the mass of this probability
distribution is on the commutant of that
group
so in other words every time you take a
sample from PSI the sampled poly
operator will commute with every element
of the stabilizer group of PSI
yes so if it's like if G has size to the
n and G perp also has size 2 again
any other questions about this
um yeah so this is really the key
property that you know the sampled poly
operators always commute with the
stabilizer group
and in fact there's actually also like a
robust version of this that holds this
requires just a little bit more effort
but you can sort of show conversely that
you know if you could find a subgroup g
perp that accounts for a large fraction
of the piece I have like a one minus
Epsilon fraction
then in fact Psy is basically Epsilon
close to some state that actually does
have G as the stabilizer group
and this is really the key property that
we use because we basically say that
like with the space means is that if you
take enough samples from uh this
distribution PSI
then eventually you will have like a
very good proxy for the stabilizer group
of geek
um and indeed uh actually believe it or
not we've already developed pretty much
all the algebraic tools that we need
I can already start stating the
algorithms that we have starting with
our pseudoanalyst distinguisher
so again
um
this algorithm it takes a state sign and
your promise that either the stabilizer
group of PSI is non-trivial so for
example a PSI is generated with strictly
less than ntps or PSI is just a r random
and qubit State
and the following algorithm that
distinguishes these two cases as follows
so you just sample a bunch of poly
operators from this distribution QSI
which as I mentioned is not exactly PSI
but it's like close enough that you know
the math works out
just take a linear number of these
samples
and you let G the the
um the Dual subgroup the commutant of
the group generated by these samples and
then you just accept or reject depending
on whether the size of this group is
greater than one or not
yes
um
why isn't your algorithm much stronger
it is it's on the next slide
but I wanted to start with the easy
phase
so the reason this case is easy so
you know if if Sonic has a non-trivial
stabilizer group then it's very easy to
show but you know buy this this Duality
property here that you know all of the
sample operators will commute with all
of the elements of G so that when you
take G to be the commutant of the
sampled operators you always get
something non-trivial
but conversely it's pretty easy to show
you can show it using this robustness
property but also just by like a direct
calculation that if you take samples
from this distribution for a high random
State then with overwhelming probability
um you will you know the samples will
not commute with anything other than the
identity and so you will with
overwhelming probability reject
um but as David pointed out uh in fact
we can actually do something even
stronger than this so in fact uh we also
have an algorithm that basically
property tests the size of the
stabilizer group of PSI
so in particular if you have a Quantum
State PSI with the property that either
PSI is stabilized by some group of
polyoperators of size at least two to
the N minus k or it is Epsilon far from
that then you can distinguish these two
cases using essentially the same
algorithm
um
so there's some dependence on Epsilon
and the number of samples but otherwise
it's still just you sample a linear
number of times from this distribution
you compute the commutant of the group
generated by those samples and then you
just accept a reject depending on
whether the size of that group is bigger
or smaller than what you expected
and once again like the way you prove
this is using this this robustness
property that you know you know
eventually by sampling enough times from
this distribution you will with
overwhelming probability find a Subspace
that accounts for a large fraction of
the PSI Mass
and then um
by taking the commutant you can sort of
be confident that that commutant uh this
resulting subgroup G approximately
stabilizes PSI
and then finally we have our state
learning algorithm where you basically
just add on this one extra step of uh
using this kind of Clifford decoder to
uh to to actually learn the state so
once again the algorithm just takes the
form of you sample a linear number of
times
um you let G be the commutant of that of
those samples
you use G to find a Clifford circuit
that approximately Maps PSI to a state
of the form just you know a tensor
product of zeros and some K qubit State
and then finally Ubuntu tomography on
Phi
and uh promise that you're given a state
that has uh you know a stabilizer group
of size at least two to the N minus k
um you approximately learn PSI to within
some error Epsilon
um so that's basically all the
algorithms are there any questions about
this
um
I thought I had something else to say
he's a multiple copy
yes uh yeah this does use multiple copy
measurements
um
it actually uses like only two copies of
the state at a time to do this Bell
sampling
um and actually for this algorithm so so
this is something we're working on now
um you actually can do uh you can
achieve a similar learning algorithm
using only single copyright
but it's still computationally efficient
it's still computationally efficient
um but I think for these other
algorithms I suspect this becomes
impossible
that might even be proven though
actually at least in the case where you
only have like this promise that the
stabilizer uh the stabilizer group is
either large or not
yeah
another question do you have a sense for
how strong the problem is
um what do you mean the sense that if I
have some Clifford plus T circuit
yes
well social benefits of Clifford plus T
circuit with uh most KT Gates it will
always satisfy the SK
okay
but with more than that then you know
who knows
so what do you think it it breaks if you
have a single copies that you mentioned
before
um
so the problem is I I don't know that
you can learn the entire stabilizer
group efficiently with single copy
measures oh okay so
um like here it's sort of okay because
the tomography algorithm takes time
that's like
um
and the single copy algorithm also takes
time that's like two to the K to learn
that stabilizer
but for this
um the point is you're like learning the
stabilizer group in polynomial time
regardless of the size
and that's the thing that I think is
hard
yeah because like
I mean I don't know if it's literally
been shown but like there were these
results showing that like if you you
know if you want to learn the
expectation of like some quality
observable
um of an unknown Quantum State then like
this is exponentially harder
uh using single copy measurements than
two copy measurements and like I feel
like something similar has to hold here
as well
um
okay so that about summarizes how the
algorithms work
um you know just to briefly recap you
know we give new algorithms for learning
these Clifford plus two states and other
states that generalize the stabilizer
group I think what's quite remarkable
about these algorithms is how
operationally simple they are you know
really all the work is just in the
analysis but the algorithms themselves
are quite simple and I think the main
take-home message is that even from
these states that generalize stabilizer
States the algebraic structure of you
know stabilizers and poly matrices is
very powerful
uh and I think I will leave you with
that
so thank you
[Applause]
questions
it's a getting polynomial sample
complexity qualities
of course the hard part in these I mean
in the straightforward algorithms
complexity can you also read one copy at
a time yes yeah because it's just like
classical Shadows
so in fact the the measurements you do
are literally just random Clifford
attachments
it's a straightforward condition on the
classical status paper yes okay
yeah
um
sorry like what do you mean like in this
algorithm well we should expect to like
know that the generator
trying to understand is your approach to
uh your acid is from uh
okay I don't know what a lot of that
means but uh I mean like we do
you know store the generators of these
stabilizer groups I don't know if that
directly answers your question
um and this one's also related to
something else someone asked earlier
which is that you know we store these
stabilizer booms in like a succinct
fashion like you just scored the
generators yeah storing the entire uh
the entire stabilizer group would
require like exponential space but
um
no it's it's like random
it's like uh click it's only clicks I
believe
um we just like apply a Clifford and
then measure
um
um anyone else
hey I have a question
does anyone know if like someone has
pooped something like this before
because I feel like there's no way that
we are like literally the first people
to observe this
so
like it's just like a very nice
algebraic property um
it's like related uh there's like a I
think an equivalent fact which is that
this function of P side is like
it's it's its own Fourier transform when
you define the Fourier transform
appropriately it's it's like for some
solutions
goodbye
I'm sure there are previous lemons that
show that one thing equals another thing
I don't know if this is a relevant
observation because it looks a lot like
the probability of winning a non-local
game in which you're playing with the
stabilizers of the state side
in that sense what you showed us a bit
like rigidity for that
oh oh like like this thing yeah
yeah it could be like
yeah I mean you know fundamentally
that's basically just like a statement
about
uh
representation Theory right
so maybe something similar is going on
here
yeah it looks similar to saying that
like if your state has like one one
has more than one Vietnamese
but yeah I mean it is you know it is
somehow using something about like The
Duality between them and also ask the
question like could you replace the
group of following matrices with some
other group instead of sure right
no I think something like this decimal
to cubits as well
because like I said I believe this is
like equivalent to some some Fourier
transform property and like this PSI W
like this was studied in the paper by
photosynatoni and Walter
um
and like you can define something
similar for higher numbers of keyboard
of cubits
uh yeah
so once you have learned the state like
how hard it is
oh good I have no idea
uh I don't think I really know anything
better than
some kind of root for us like I mean
okay you can
you can find some circuit that prepares
that state fine it will have size two
into the K so it's like an exponential
blow up in the number of non-cliffer
gates potential
and I don't know anything that feeds
that
was another question is
sorry say that again can you extend this
let me know what do you think
noise
oh including noise
um
if it's just like single qubit
depolarizing noise for example I don't
believe so I think I've even seen a
claim that like learning even stabilizes
shapes is hard
because depolarizing noise like
information theoretically
but I'm not certain about that but I
definitely know that these algorithms
break
yeah
um but yeah yeah that's a good question
um these algorithms are very non-noise
robust
just first um
somehow on a high level very similar to
Simon so everything
else
a bunch of strings and then you want to
learn what's the Spanish
[Applause]
so um you said with single copies and
then time two to the K you can learn the
stabilizer group
so with two copies is it like even
faster than it doesn't depend okay or
yeah with two copies
um like
I mean so you learn like an
approximation to the stabilizer group
right because like okay so I could be
you know arbitrarily as close to some
state
that that doesn't have exactly that
stabilization
that's like this
yeah I believe this algorithm is
basically optimal and it's impossible to
say like super briefly how the single
copy level
um is it possible
so
I mean it's morally similar like so what
happens is um
okay if you like take a random
stabilizer state
um no if you take the stabilizer State
and measure it in a random Clifford
basis
there is some probability that
um
the the support of that state in the
computational basis will be a proper
affine Subspace of uh all and bit screen
so the measurements are random typically
well it's like you pick a random Clipper
but then you have to measure like uh end
times
so you pick a random Liberty measure
however many times from this from that
basis
and basically
um if you see that you are in a proper
affine Subspace of F2 to the N
um that tells you a generator of the
stabilizer group so this is actually
basically the the errant and goddessing
algorithm for landing stabilizer States
in a way we're just observing that you
can kind of do the same thing even if
you have a statement that's not a
stabilizer state but that has a
non-trivial state level
but the problem is you need to take like
the number of samples you need to take
before you find like a good Clifford you
know scales with like a
two to the k or something
anyone else
all right well thank you William thank
you
foreign